hundreds of thousands of ukrainians are
trying to get out of their country to
escape those russian forces a lot of
them have walked many miles to get to
the nearest border where they find
extremely long lines un says up to four
million people could be displaced by the
fighting poland already has allowed more
than 200 thousand ukrainians to enter
their country
chris libsay is at a border checkpoint
in the city of madika in poland
just a heartbreaking reality for
ukrainians fleeing bloodshed at home and
now a log jam here at the exit dozens
line up for food and water after waiting
for days just to flee the country we
knew that it was like
something like a war but we didn't know
that it will be actually like on
our like whole ukraine war the russian
invasion is ripping apart their homes
the u.n says pushing more than 360 000
refugees to flee most of them to poland
which is just on the other side of that
crossing so close but it's a bottleneck
cars buses trucks all lined up for miles
some carry children some carry pets just
anything they could grab in a hurry
notice most people here are women and
children men of fighting age have been
ordered to stay in ukraine possibly to
fight in this new conflict between putin
and the west for cbs morning's chris
livesay on the ukraine border
chris livesay reporting from the border
chris thank you very much it's been
pointed out by others guys and it
doesn't escape our notice as well that
while these refugees are being welcomed
into these neighboring countries of
ukraine that has not always been the
case in poland in 2015 uh refugees from
africa and the middle east uh met a
different uh degree of welcome and
sometimes no welcome at all so it's a
difference that we're gonna be staying
on top of and trying to get a full
picture of what is the worst refugee
crisis since world war ii and in fact
more people are displaced today than at
any time since world war ii globally big
picture every country yeah the numbers
are staggering most of those refugees
are women and children because of men
between the ages of 18 and 60 are being
told we need you here and most of them
say we want to stay fight for our
country